[Musique]
je ne vous dévoilerai pas un secret en
vous disant que nous vivons dans une
société à risques risques technologiques
l'exemple le plus frappant de cette
année c'est la sphère des fûts de
dioxine de seveso
mais aussi et surtout au risque social
dans une période de crise où le chômage
se développe inéluctablement nos
sociétés rejettent sans pitié ceux qui
ont le malheur de décrocher si j'ose
dire à un moment ou à un autre de leur
vie
or les appelle aujourd'hui les nouveaux
pauvres bien souvent des jeunes d'une
trentaine d'années que vous rencontrez
dans les grandes villes
complètement à la dérive des nouveaux
pauvres il y en a de plus en plus
rejetée dans les marges d'un monde où le
chacun pour soi est la règle un
reportage de jean marc dubois daniel
cattelain et gibert usant
[Musique]
on sait jamais si vous allez faire la
manche comme enjeu la paix bon c'est
bien le tout de bien boire vous sentir
un peu notre ressenti un peu dans le
village
ce que je voudrais c'est m'en sortir
[Musique]
voilà c'est parti cet homme n'a pas
trente ans il y a trois ans il était
ouvrier il a été licencié et alors il a
plongé il est devenu clochard d'alcool a
remplacé le travail
il fait partie de tout ce que l'on
appelle les nouveaux pauvres dans le
jargon et sociale va être pauvre c'est
avoir des revenus en dessous d'un
minimum permettant de vivre en général
on évalue sa à la moitié du smig et
c'est ce qu'on appelle le quart monde
ces personnes là ces nouveaux pauvres
sont des personnes qui travaillaient qui
s'assumait qui touchait un salaire qui
était peut-être à la limite mais qui
vivait qui pouvaient se loger se nourrir
et qui par la suite la perte de l'emploi
et de l'aider longueur administrative se
retrouvent brutalement exclus ils sont
plusieurs milliers sans emploi sans
domicile sans ressources
7000 à paris beaucoup de célibataires
souvent des hommes jeunes à la recherche
d'un emploi beaucoup de femmes
abandonnées avec leurs enfants
alors pour eux c'est le centre des
dossiers économiques
et comme j'ai 55 ans le baume présenté
côté monsieur comprendre poliment que
vous êtes trop vieux pour disposer de
combien d'argent par jour pour vivre et
réalité cet affreux s'était d'abord son
procès allongé faut penser être logés
mais s'il était passé chez des amis
n'est-ce pas serais à la rue mais la rue
c'est ce qui est arrivé à cette femme
abandonnée par son mari avec ses deux
enfants
il habite maintenant est provisoirement
dans un foyer du secours catholique
après avoir beaucoup chercher car les
foyers n'acceptent pas facilement les
enfants nés dans les foyers bon bah y
avait pas de place dans ce roman à
l'avant dans d'autres on n'acceptait pas
l'enfant qui n'allaient pas à l'école
n'ont d'autre prenez pas la fin du tour
c'est mon état je voulais garder les
enfants la 1er place mais certains
arrivent à s'en sortir sans sortir ça
veut dire retrouver l'anonymat
redevenir normal avoir un emploi à
domicile
comme ce jeune couple qui était depuis
deux ans au chômage là j'ai fait un
stage de j'ai eu du diplôme d'animation
par la préfecture de police
avec succès des succès deux examens
nationaux service réanimation
j'ai terminé le 28 novembre mais je vais
travailler je pense mais pour un qui
arrive à s'en sortir qui émerge de sa
misère un autre il plonge définitivement
alors c'est la cloche la soupe populaire
et le métro parfois deux
[Musique]
on les appelle les nouveaux topo le
terme n'est pas forcément bien choisie
mais il lit bien ce qu'il veut dire
la crise économique a fait naître une
nouvelle catégorie de classes
défavorisées en majorité des français
des jeunes qui ne touchent plus aucune
allocation et détail important il
utilise paraît-il les consignes
automatique des gars comme vestiaire ou
encore comme appartement l'enquète de
jérôme money et de bruno qu'avec pardon
monsieur pourriez vous m'aider pour
pouvoir manger
pardon monsieur
pardon monsieur pourriez vous m'aider
pour pouvant alors s'il vous plaît
pourriez vous m'aider pour pouvoir
manger surnom
il me faudrait trouver du travail
la possibilité de trouver
georgette faire la mendicité porte sur
sauf que je cherche je cherche du boulot
tous les matins à 6 heures du matin j'ai
absolument et
je préférais entre trouvé que l'optique
de me mettre à voler sans ressources
mes parents j'ai pu s'arranger plus rien
plus d'amis je suis obligé de faire ça
pour pouvoir survivre souvient jeudi à
ouistreham du calvados notre dame du
travail cgt boulanger métier j'ai eu un
poumon de brûler je peux plus d'exercer
pour la première fois depuis l'appel de
l'abbé pierre en 1954
emmaüs a dû reprendre cette année les
distributions de soupe populaire dans la
région parisienne ils sont huit mille
sdf sans domicile fixe clochard mais
aussi jeunes chômeurs comme dominique il
a ni l'autre n'auraient pu imaginer il
ya quelques mois qu'il boire et cette
soupe
ils font partie des 200 mille chômeurs
ne touchant aucune indemnité journalière
jetés à la rue sans un centime en poche
dominique et yvon dorment trois heures
par nuit dans une épave de voiture
oublié par la fourrière
un mois ça se passe mal ça fait un mois
qu'on est l'entrée de bagnoles on trouve
pas de logements pour pas de boulot mais
ça fait un mois qu'on dort ici
on a froid mais du bruit mais vraiment
crevé qu'est ce que tu faisais comme
travail j'étais dans le bâtiment peintre
petit nom je suis tombé malade et mon
patron m'a viré à ce qui fait que je me
retrouve là la rue qui répond bien avec
rien
j'ai rien je fais la manche et de ce
populaire il n'ya pas d'être déçus de
l'aide sociale de 1 20 franc tous les
tous les mois elle chômage chômage non
j'ai pas droit parce que j'ai pas
travailler assez longtemps pour
bénéficier du fond des temps en temps ça
se passe maintenant temps on fait les
boîtes intérimaire mais c'est difficile
quand il ya on n'est pas les seuls
beaucoup de monde sur une place il faut
arriver à 6 ans le matin il ya déjà
trente personnes pour faire la queue
c'est pas évident pour trouver quelque
chose
enfin on arrive on arrive quand même à
survivre sans tout ce qui compte le plus
c'est rester propre parce que ça ça
compte pour pouvoir se présenter à
droite ou à gauche ça ça compte
et puis bon ben j'ai à tous les quinze
jours on va laver notre linge dans un
self service derrière pour pouvoir
rester correct venus de normandie il
passe tous les matins au syndicat de la
boulangerie
en vain il est à la rue avec sa femme et
sa fillette de deux ans
[Musique]
on a remis au volant
avec la petite
donc mais dehors pas dans le métro
bien oui couverture tout ça
et avec votre famille vous vivez avec
combien par jour pourrait en fait la
manche on sait bien qu'ils me veulent
mes hanches et épaules
[Musique]
bobigny
daniel quant à lui refuse de faire la
manche
il vit avec 10 francs par jour de quoi
se payer un paquet de cigarettes et
quelques cafés tous ses repas lui sont
fournies par les soupes populaires
d'emmaüs ou de l'armée du salut
et depuis le 24 décembre je suis sans
travail j'avais fait d'une mission
j'avais travaillé pendant six mois dans
une maison intérim en tant que promoteur
vendeurs pas descendre
travail interrompu qu'une mission c'est
donc deux mois et demi que je ne
travaille plus je me suis inscrit aux
assedic et j'attends le versement des
assedic qui ne parviendra dans dans deux
mois environ
en attendant je suis démunis et
c'est comme solution de coucher dans le
métro tous les foyers de la région
parisienne sont complets et refusent des
centaines de chômeurs chaque jour il y a
dans tout paris 4000 lits pour 8000 sans
logis certains de ces lits sont occupés
par des personnes qui ont trouvé un
travail régulier et pourrait louer un
studio
seulement voilà les propriétaires sont
devenus trop exigeant difficile de
rappeler sur ces images qui lie à 120
mille appartements inoccupés à paris
[Musique]